[Musique]
françaises français
la france a choisi son président merci
peuple de france ici rassemblés devant
leur permet d'être votre président de la
république cette confiance elle me laure
et l mangal
[Musique]
il fallait nourrir tour
je salue la france
nous avons tant à faire ensemble et tend
à dire aussi
maintenant c'est à mon tour de vendre à
la france ce que la france m'a donné
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
vous l'avez emporté la france l'emporté
c'est pas la gauche la france c'est pas
la daurade la france
[Musique]
la franche c'est tout à la fois la
république et liva 30
[Musique]
bon
alors je vais vous demander de vous
mettre un trottoir
aucun accident il vous plait
christian jacob parcours partie des
répétitions est attendue d'une minute à
l'autre pour faire l'annoncé des
résultats du premier tour du congrès les
républicains qui doit désigner ce sa
musique le candidat de la droite à la
bhl
[Musique]
ces panneaux pro
la meilleure pour
[Musique]
il
c'est à vous
grâce à bond surtout beaucoup
yann engel ciotti a recueilli quelque 44
410 voix 39 % 39 à +0 5%
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de prise de vue en tout
je suis à 476 photo et j'envoie 18
photos je les ai envoyées isabelle qui
est permanence ce week-end et qui va les
injecter sur le web
souvent les bonnes photos se font dans
les à côtés ou dans les contretemps
après on peut aussi en faire de bonnes
sur un podium mais voilà toujours trouvé
le contretemps l'instant le blanc sur
une partition de la musique
l'intérêt c'est d'en avoir plusieurs
bien sûr et si possible pas forcément là
mais sur des séquences de raconter un
peu l'histoire notamment quand on subit
quelqu'un sur une journée
[Musique]
une campagne présidentielle c'est le
graal du de la photographie politique
les campagnes présidentielles le début
des campagnes c'est toujours les
meilleurs moments pour les photographes
c'est là on fait les photos les les
les plus
parfois les plus intrigants parce qu'on
se retrouve dans des situations parfois
on est seul avec des candidats en début
de campagne présidentielle il n'y a pas
tout ce barnum c'est pour ça que je fais
aussi des politiques c'est poursuivre
les campagnes présidentielles une femme
pour le voir évoluer partir à la
conquête du pays quoi
et quand je suis retourné en sur la
photographie politique pour le monde en
2005 et un suivant ségolène royal des
fois je trouve je retrouvé la même
ferveur dans une salle de politique donc
dans une salle de meeting pendant la
campagne présidentielle que dans une
cérémonie vaudou du bout du monde tout
est question de pouvoir
tout est question de sacrés comme sacrée
et d'imaginaire à ce que les politiques
font aussi appel à ça pour amener des
votes je crois que tout est lié et
vos dauphin vaudou religion sacrée
imaginaire politique conquête du pouvoir
se sont dès à peu près 20 de choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une femme livre et j'entends le rester
on est au tout début de la campagne de
ségolène royal en 2006 en août 2006 et
on est à la fête de la rose à frangy en
bresse et au niveau du sol où on est sur
cette prime une je vois les pieds de
ségolène royal avec des pétales de roses
des roses posé par terre dis donc je
fais cette photo des pieds
avec les fleurs j'envoie mon journal à
libération qui pour parler du lancement
de la campagne de la candidate publie
une photo de ses pieds avec les roses
ski en 2006 et est un élément important
puisque c'est quand même la première
femme qui va être désigné candidat du ps
à la présidentielle là il ya eu un petit
drame alors on a en 2006 on n'a pas les
réseaux sociaux on est beaucoup moins
connectés donc il n'y a pas ce qu'on
appelle un cheat storm quand je vais à
l'université d'été de la rochelle le
week-end qui suit je me fais engueuler
par des députés qui me disent amis de
ségolène royal qui me disent que
j'aurais jamais fait ça pour un homme
chose que j'ai déjà fait pour des hommes
j'ai fait des alignements de rangées de
mocassins plus ou moins bien cirées au
premier rang des meetings j'ai fait ce
genre de choses alors pourquoi on fait
ça
parce que le costume politique fait
partie du job est fait partie de la
communication politique on voit que
c'est des chaussures qui sont un peu
abîmée donc voilà ça dit la route ça dit
mickael va partir en campagne et que
donc du coup les chaussons sont déjà
visés mais que
elle va y aller c'est une photo qui
décrit les mois qui vont arriver moi
j'étais content de la du travail que
j'avais fait avec françois hollande sur
sa campagne parce que parce qu'il y
avait quand même la proximité encore sa
campagne était était assez dense et est
très axé sur
les gens il y avait énormément de
déplacement il y avait beaucoup de
contacts
est effectivement sur la campagne de
2011 2012 puisque je vais intégrer la
primaire qui avait lieu on l'a vu
arriver avec les transformations
physiques et a beaucoup maigri
il a hidden hills et enlever les
oripeaux de premier secrétaire du parti
pour prendre celui de candidat
donc voilà c'est une campagne qui était
assez dynamique un finalement
photographiquement notre boulot c'est de
d'enregistrer ces transformations et
l'impact qu'a l'actualité et quand tous
ces événements sur le personnage
politique - c'est ce que j'ai vu avec
françois hollande en 2012 avec ségolène
royal en 2007 aussi c'était assez
intéressant de voir des moments j'ai
pris un coup là les sondages sont au
plus bas la campagne marche pas je suis
tout seul sur le quai de la gare c'est
un tout c'est vraiment un bar se nage
qui draine un ensemble comme ça un petit
peu comme un cirque où un groupe de rock
en tournée et on voit s'il ya plus de
monde dans les salles ou pas quoi
[Musique]
j'adore l'immersion et en politique tout
est exacerbé puisque on a envie de
savoir ce qui se passe derrière la porte
mwa ji était et je pouvais le montrer
donc j'essayais de saisir pas tous les
moments mais les meilleurs moments parce
que j'ai plein de photos et les
meilleurs moments c'est effectivement
quand la jacques séguéla argumente sur
la campagne présidentielle et sur une
affiche de campagne sur lequel
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas le nom de lionel
jospin et je me souviens que ça avait
suscité un petit débat
[Musique]
sur une période assez longue c'est vrai
que le noir et blanc m'a permis de
même mois inconsciemment de rendre un
peu artistique mes photos ou d'essayer
de me décaler un peu et finalement ça se
différencier beaucoup mais parution dans
les journaux parce que justement c'était
de l'exclusivité en noir et blanc donc
ça exacerber un tout petit peu la
dramaturgie du moment et en plus comme
il a perdu ça exacerbe aussi la
dramaturgie de toute la période de la
campagne présidentielle
[Musique]
par contre le regard du photographe sait
qu'on peut devenir un peu empathique que
nous on observe et je je je je le
connaissais par coeur il y en a je n'ose
pas de ses cheveux aux pantalons à ces
attitudes à ses mimiques je savais quand
il était énervé j'avais quand il était
détendu et parfois j'utilisais ces
occasions là pour peut-être lui demander
des choses en plus ou pour intervenir
mais souvent je la photographie nous
permettent un peu d'aller plus loin et
d'aller voir le personnage quand on
observe quelqu'un presque 12 heures sur
et sarkozy était
sarkozyste autre chose c'était la bête
politique c'était voilà c'était c'était
comment dire
il était déjà lancée dans une carrière
il était c'était une machine il était
entouré il était dévoilée c'est
quelqu'un qui avait une volonté très
forte de réussir d'être président et qui
était très bien entouré avec des gens
qui maîtrisent est cette chose c'était
un mastodonte et donc on n'arrivait pas
trop avoir de proximité avec lui c'était
déjà la grogne à grande carriole avec
avec avec 1000 journalistes autour de
lui et ça très très tôt c'était
différent
alors celui qui a fait la photo de la
charrette il a montré dispositif
entièrement c'est ça notre boulot aussi
c'est de montrer le dispositif entier de
communication la folie du monde
politico-médiatique moi c'est quelque
chose que j'essaie toujours de faire de
faire rentrer dans le cadre plus large
que politique puisque est formidable
c'est d'avoir fait la photo de la meute
maîtrisé par le communicant
de l'homme sur lequel on communique et
on voit tout et tout est dit
on s'est pas rendu compte de l'image que
ça pouvait rendre surtout de notre
candidat parce qu'au final c'est pas
tant les gens et qu'ils sont ridicules
c'est le candidat à côté de ces
journalistes à qui est ridicule vous
êtes pompidou à la pêche à la crevette
et lahi la pêche à quoi va-t-il en boxer
short bleu on est dans les années 60 30
boxer short bleu plus il a toujours sa
cigarette mais simplement il ya un
photographe devant lui c'est françois
pagès et françois keller photographique
le futur président n'est pas encore
président joie dans une situation de
monsieur mais dans tout le monde mais
je ne sais pas s'il va naturellement à
la pêche à la crevette mais l'image
qu'il veut donner de lui d'homme simple
en train de pêcher la crevette avec sa
clope là ça fonctionne donc c'est vrai
si en contrechamp vous avez 60
journalistes sur un radeau en train de
photographier
la pêche à la crevette ça devient
ridicule et sarkozy sur son choix était
ridicule
[Musique]
sa voix rauque à travailler
j'ai en tête une photo de d'andré
personne qui se fait tôt au congrès de
metz en 1979 et c'était le lieu de
l'affrontement entre rocard et et
mitterrand ces trois jours
trois jours de congrès et là je suis en
mission il faut que je photographie
regard et mitterrand en somme l'idée
c'était d'essayer d'avoir la photo qui
montrerait quelque chose de la relation
hostile à ce moment là entre les deux
zones et je sais qu'en voyant mitterrand
se lever je sais que dans l'âtre il va
passer derrière
rocard à la tribune donc je compte je
suis mitterrand ou est-ce qu'il va il va
aux toilettes
je l'attend à la sortie des toilettes et
puis je prends de l'avant ce jeu fait le
point sur eux quartier comme ça la fois
content et j'attends que mitterrand
passe derrière lui et il passe et il eut
le fusille du regard
[Musique]
et là j'ai un choc et j'entends derrière
moi salo tu l'as eu parce que les
collègues qui m'ont vu il était pas là
[Musique]
françois mitterrand m'a impressionné par
son attitude son espèce de con côté très
élégant avec une profonde gentillesse et
de respect et pas du tout
voyez l'homme politique qui en fait des
tonnes parce qu'il veut plaire me tente
pas du tout mais il faudra afficher un
personnage comme ça pour moi c'est un
personnage qui m'a impressionné vraiment
impressionné la quatrième république est
née dès le premier tour monsieur vincent
auriol président de l'assemblée
nationale était élue à la majorité
absolue
lisez la foule parisienne attendaient 7
au milieu des acclamations que le nouvel
élu à la suprême magistrature du pays
pénétrez dans cette cour ride depuis
bientôt sept ans le seuil photographique
de l'elysée a été créée sous la
quatrième république
à l'initiative du président vincent
auriol en 1952 il me semble que vincent
auriol un peu à l'image d'un de ses
successeurs à derry giscard d'estaing se
sont b des présidents qui ont qui ont
souhaité laisser une trace
documentaire de l'activité qui était la
leur
[Musique]
e
au départ les photographes de l'elysée
sont tous des militaires et notamment
des gardes républicains qui vous le
savez sont chargés de la sécurité des
palais des palais nationaux
de manière très symptomatique le premier
reportage réalisé en 1952 par ce nouveau
service photographies de l'elysée ce
n'est pas un reportage à l'elysée mais
c'est une reportage dans la résidence
privée à muret
chez vincent auriol de vincent auriol
donc cette sorte de représentation du
chef de l'état hors de ses fonctions
plutôt dans des fonctions privées
donc il ya là une volonté me semble-t-il
de montrer le chef de l'état un peu
comme aurait dit l'un de ses successeurs
un homme normal
[Musique]
avec effectivement l'arrivée au pouvoir
du général de gaulle et le service
photographique va devoir représenter le
chef de l'état donc le présent de la
vème république dans tout finalement ses
missions alors sous le général de gaulle
sous georges pompidou sous valéry
giscard d'estaing ce sont effectivement
les gardes républicains qui sont
affectés au service photographies de
l'elysée jusqu'à la fin du septennat de
françois mitterrand ça ce sont des
activités qui rythment le calendrier du
chef de l'état les audiences des
ambassadeurs les réceptions des chefs
d'état étrangers alors je pense qu'il ya
une rupture avec nicolas sarkozy en fait
qui lui va utiliser la photographie hull
élyséenne à des fins de communication et
va être le premier à mettre en oeuvre le
site internet de la présidence de la
république et à illustrer ce site
internet avec les photographies de
l'elysée c'est à dire que là on change
perspective on met à disposition des
citoyens immédiatement la représentation
figurée du chef de l'état
[Musique]
c'était jacques chirac qui disait une
photo c'est une voix en 2012 faut bien
se souvenir que les selphy ça n'existait
pas ou très peu et en fait nous on a
continué à envoyer pendant trois quatre
ans beaucoup de photos à des gens quand
je dis une photo c'est une voix cccc
c'est pas helix électoraliste mais c'est
anecdotique mais les gens apprécient
s'ils se font prendre en photo c'est pas
pour que la photo elle reste dans les
archives nationales de l'elysée c'est
pour qu'il les reçoive et ça rentrait
dans le budget du service photo de
l'elysée où il était prévu qu'on envoie
des photos à des gentils remettait
pareil des projets des dossiers
[Musique]
la sortie du conseil des ministres à la
place des photographes dans la cour de
l'elysée et un thermomètre à ça
intéressant si on regarde affectivement
les images d archives dans les années 60
les 60 70 les photographes qui suivent
les actualités la politique à la sortie
du conseil des ministres ils sont sur
les marches de l'elysée sur le perron
après dans les années 20 80 90 ah bah
ils sont des sortes de démarches et ils
sont derrière des plots dans la cour
mais malgré tout ils peuvent toujours
suivre quand les ministres vent à leur
voiture il ya un peu le un peu
d'agitation un peu de bordel pour les
suivre est là il se passe des choses
dans les années 2000 ah bah on est
encore plus loin on est derrière des
plots et on peut plus vivre nulle part
et on fait tout de loin et en fait il ya
un recul comme ça mais un recul réel
géographique dans la cour de l'elysée
qui correspond à un recul par rapport
aux politiques à ce corps à ce qui veut
dire à l'événement à l'actualité
politique
[Musique]
le lendemain de la passation de pouvoir
en 2007 libération en bois dans la cour
de l'elysée une disons bazille tu verra
bien ce que tu fais et ce jour là
à un moment on est sorti de la cour et
les ja le cortège présidentiel avec le
président sarkozy qui s'en va et en fait
on ne savait pas où ils allaient et nous
nos copains photographe no 10 a on a
fait une série de photos avec fillon en
train de faire un jogging dans le bois
de dans le bois de boulogne évidemment
nous photographes on s'est dit bon bah
on a loupé la photo du jour parce que
l'on s'est dit voilà sur l'actu du jour
ce jour là c'était cette photo de
sarkozy et son premier ministre faisait
un jogging et puis un moment on rentre
dans la cour de l'elysée et on entend
les sirènes du cortège qui arrivent et
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
ils m'ont pas nous le déposer en short
là au milieu sur la cour et puis si on
était trois photographes un peu perdue
comme ça comme dans les dessins de sempé
et la grande cour de l'elysée vous avez
trois petits photographes et puis le
gros carthage elysées qui arrive
paimpont toute lumière allumée hélas la
portière sourd et on voit nicolas
sarkozy petites foulées
traversé la cour montée en courant les
marches de l'elysée et errants est
rentré dans le palais de l'elysée ça a
l'air de rien mais on n'a jamais dans
l'histoire de la république française
photographier un président en exercice
en short et tennis sur le perron de
l'elysée qui est un lieu extrêmement
protocolaire peut-être le plus
protocolaire de la république nicolas
sarkozy était en total look night
chaussettes chaussures short tee-shirt
avec une breitling au
poignet et le blackberry à la main et ça
m'a fait beaucoup sourire tout le
sarkozysme qui démarrait était vraiment
rempli dans ce moment et dans cette
image
en dix ans de règne les roulements
derniers
travaux du conseil des ministres allait
pas heureusement je suis candidat que
souvent talk santé souriant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui valéry giscard d'estaing en 1974
viallon remporte l'élection
présidentielle sur la communication et
sur la modernité que cette nouvelle
communication qu'il avait peut-être
perçu lors de voyages aux états unis il
avait notamment rencontré kennedy en
1963 alors qu'il était ministre des
finances donc il avait perçu que la
communication
dans au début de ces années 70 jouer un
rôle considérable lorsque il demanda
sauveur de couvrir par exemple ça sa
campagne en 74 sauveur c'est le
photographe d'hemingway de picasso de
brigitte bardot de ou de romy schneider
donc c'était pas le photographe des
hommes politiques
était d'un souk où un président qui
voulaient exprimer une sorte de
convivialité c'est la première fois
qu'on voyait une photo de campagne
électorale qui était quand même un côté
un peu ça me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un homme jeune de
46 ou 47 ans 74 qui a une fille qui est
donc
comme tous les français passent à créer
une proximité incroyable et par son
propre comportement ils jouent au
football
il joue de l'accordéon
voilà il y avait une véritable modernité
qui tranchait d'ailleurs beaucoup avec
mitterrand qui était lui un homme de la
quatrième république et qui était plus
dans la position
ira tic du général de gaulle
[Musique]
c'était bien là
la milice était bien comme ça alors
c'est bien parce que jusque là
ici vous savez il ya des ados
l'exubérance dans tous les sens alors
ces limitations
[Musique]
laval
il y a une vraie rupture en 1974 avec
cette photographie de lartigue qui va
représenter effectivement le chef de
l'état j'allais dire dans une forme de
simplicité en costume cravate sent
effectivement le port du du collier de
la légion d'honneur au cou donc il ya là
une véritable rupture quand on voit
aujourd'hui des photos archives de cette
séance de photos pour la photo
officielle il ya jacques henri lartigue
et valéry giscard d'estaing qui sont
tous les deux tout seul ils font la
photo les personnes derrière devant et
est donc évidemment on avait dit à
jacquard en arctique de faire des photos
légèrement en contre plongée pour éviter
le côté crâne d'oeuf de giscard lartigue
s'avance avance avance au fur et à
mesure de la séance de prises de vues
jusqu'à ne retenir plus que la tête de
valéry giscard d'estaing et le drapeau
kedar jaeglé blanche donc c'est assez
c'est un vrai travail de photographe et
comment la prise de vue et les séances
de prises de vues a évolué
[Musique]
je pense que la communication par la
fiche est en effet
importante parce qu'elle
aggrave une image c'est aussi important
que la photo dans un journal sur un
article
c'est elle qui donne qui fait passer
alors c'est de la communication mais qui
fait passer
un message
la photo de mitterrand en 80 avec petit
clocher derrière
ça illustre d'ailleurs parfaitement le
la vérité du personnage m'ont dit
beaucoup sur lui sur son ancrage
terriens et il fait un lien entre paris
et la province
[Musique]
il y avait d'abord l'express il ya eu le
point puis y avait quand même les laly
star des stars les photographes stars en
burberry ce et le leica qui ont fait
marcher d'une main et c'était
photographe de match coco d'un pouce
twilight voilà c'est ma place un doigt
donc c'était ça matches 1 quand il y
avait un événement les mâles les
photographes de match était prioritaire
est en train en avion du président et
qui et nous on prenait le train mais
c'était sympathique 1 je raconte ça je
raconte mais c'était l'ambiance
[Musique]
à paris match un peu politique à
l'ancienne quoi c'est une belle vitrine
pour le politique parce qu'il sait que
en général il sera pas trop mal traités
il sera plutôt mis en valeur et il sait
à qui s'adresse c'est à dire à des gens
qui sont plutôt bienveillant ils ont
ramené des scoops paris match ils ont
ramené donc en politique il ya eu des
choses ou où il ya eu du clash où il ya
eu des enjeux il ya eu il ya eu des
choses mais globalement c'est un peu la
politique pépère quoi à l'ancienne on
est en famille avec son chien jardin
dimanche matin c'est la famille ricoré
de la politique bon bah j'ai un public
pour ça macron s et ceux à 10 ans
photographe et ce président qui
effectivement intégré l'image peu
paradis comme faisant partie du
storytelling d'un président
donc si je voulais résumé d'une formule
c'est nous
maintenant je me tiens le cas et
j'accélère avec le gouvernement l'allier
et de danic ultime question
plus personnelle des journaux people ou
montrent ces jours-ci plus de vacances
qu'est-ce que ça après le président de
la république montré ainsi est ce que
vous
condamnez est ce que vous comprenez
je vous dirai pas ce que j'éprouve vous
imaginerez ce que je pense c'est que
ça j'ai pas de respecter une personne
s'agit de respecter une fonction
c'est pas un intérêt privé qui est en
cause
c'est un intérêt aussi
nationale
chacun bâtisse où j'ai même
pour des arguments commerciaux c'est un
soap opéra au sommet de l'état s'est il
a beaucoup critiqué sarkozy il a
beaucoup trouvé ça très vulgaire etc et
et
il veut
la vie privée n'est pas un sujet pour
lui et paradoxalement c'est le président
qui va donner le plus de grain à moudre
à la presse sur sa vie personnelle mais
messi ses ex compagne avant de faire
pour lui le virage je pense c'est en
2006 un jour arrive des photos de
ségolène royal en maille banque qui a
était pas parader avec françois hollande
on va mettre claire chazal seins nus en
haut à droite qui est une valeur sûre de
de chaque été de la presse people enfin
on va se rassurer en mettant des les
personnages un peu fort autour on va
l'intitulé 1,50 stars à la plage et
numéro va très très bien se vendre je
pense que traiter sous cet angle là avec
l'idée de madame tout le monde qui la
sous tend il ya une idée proximité qui
s'installe et on sait que la proximité
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui manque aux
hommes et aux femmes politiques et là on
va être à lui signer par le par le bruit
fait autour d'eux autour de ces images à
la presse classique c'est incroyablement
bouche et le nez
a parlé d rival anglo saxon et quand un
an mais un an jour pour jour quasiment
plus tard le jdd fait une une qui parle
du programme politique de ségolène royal
et c'est une photo de planck c'est une
photo d'elle sur la plage qui rien à
voir avec une photo posée du d'une femme
politique qui expose son programme et ça
sort et ça choque plus personne wes
l'aspect people qui a démarré voilà avec
autour de 2007 avec la campagne de
nicolas sarkozy et ségolène royal ou là
il ya eu une espèce de course à
l'échalote un peu people des débuts au
détriment de ségolène royal qui a joint
un peu mais qui n'avait plus subi au
début et puis nicolas sarkozy qu'il
verra carrément joué là dessus et nous a
vendu sa femme ses enfants sa vie son
jogging son vélo en 2007 chose qui
n'existait pas avant avec carla devant
décidé d'assumer et d'assumer quoi en
décembre nous avons l'idée originale
d'aller avec son fils à disney
il ya des photos j'ai bien très bien si
ces photos sont trop douloureuse
n'envoyez plus de photographes le nous
ferons une raison c'est la première fois
qu'il m'arrive une people paparazzi dans
présent de la république donc c'est ça
paraît aujourd'hui en 2021 bon pourquoi
pas mais en 2008 c'est un truc quoi donc
la pression elle est quand même assez
ouais elle est quand même assez
importante et lorsqu'on l'a été en
egypte en vacances on a décidé et
extraordinaire de visiter les pyramides
ier original
et si vous avez peur d'être
instrumentalisés n'envoyez pas de
photographes nos vacances seront
excellence quand même dire qu'on ne peut
pas comprendre les six premiers mois de
nicolas sarkozy si on ne sait pas ce qui
se passe dans son couple il est
déboussolé moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'il
fallait mettre une barrière mais ce
qu'elle doit être absolue quand vous
voyez que la vie privée d'un homme
est tellement sur son comportement
politique battre en tentant même il faut
sans tout exposé il faut essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe pour analyser
le comportement politique de quelqu'un
oui on a osé sortir des choses mais on
n'était pas en attente de l'interview
de tel ou tel ministre on n'était pas en
attente d'un voyage présidentiel
nous allons bientôt arriver au niveau de
la place des invalides
avec à nouveau toute une meute de
photographes de reporter de caméraman
qui suit donc la voiture du président de
la république avec jacques chirac y est
ovationné j'ai l'impression d'être
d'être à longchamp dans la dernière
course du prix de l'arc de triomphe
parce que le motard j'étais derrière lui
j'essayais de le pousser dans ses
retranchements pour qu'ils approchent
pour qu'ils approchent
vous avez encore les images je crois de
là
leur motoneige s'est fait qu'ils suivent
la voiture du chef de l'état après cette
balade romantique sur les bords de seine
pour aller de la mairie jusqu'au qg de
présidentielle enfin le qg de son parti
il monte les étages et il sort il sort
de la demande sur le balcon il n'y a pas
de balcon mayence est assez dangereux
bernadette à côté qui ne veulent retenir
par le pantalon mais j'ai pas vu moi
j'étais en bas avec tous les gens qui
étaient autour au balcon évidemment il y
avait quelqu'un qui avait un drapeau
bleu blanc rouge enfin la composition
était parfaite
[Applaudissements]
au sein des agences y avait toujours un
photographe qui suivait tel personnage
moi c'était chirac la droite d'autres
appellent la gauche mitterrand
les communistes le pen tout ça dans
l'esprit de fidéliser un peu le le
personnage et qui s'habituent aux
photographes pour essayer d'avoir dit en
gros c'était d'avoir les exclusivités
avec lui jean en famille
et puis le personnage et
surtout chirac un plus que les autres
mais était quand même c'est intéressant
à suivre photo graphiquement parlant
quoi il ya une gestuelle aussi en même
temps et une gestuelle et ça provoque un
éclat de rire de l'eau du voilà si nous
on est là pour aux aguets quoi mais
alors il ne fait pas je pense pas qu'il
ne fait il ne fait pas pou pasquier des
photographes il le fait parce qu'il est
il est totalement naturelle il était
totalement naturel
on est dans le mélange de l'histoire de
l'actualité il ya toutes ces choses là
qui se télescopent elle anticipe ce qui
va se passer le soir même elle raconte
quelque chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un homme politique qui étaient
jeunes qui étaient un peu charismatique
des baux un peu un peu comme obama un
peu c'est comme ça ce qu'on disait sur
obama c'était le gars qui était coûte
quoi qu'il fasse obama et moi je suis
cacahuètes il le fait avec la plus
grande classe du monde quoi macron est
un petit peu comme ça et un sourire on
peut lui donner comme ça excédent il ya
plein d'informations qui peuvent se
greffer là dans plein de symbolique
plutôt pas beaucoup d'informations à
cette photo mais y'a de la symbolique et
le sourire en politique c'est ce
qui fait les hommes et les femmes
politiques il faut sourire pour être
rassurant pour qu'on nous élisent il
faut être grand il faut être beau il
faut être fort
[Musique]
la communication des manuels macron elle
se rapproche de la communication
d'entreprise la communication politique
elle a ses qualités ses défauts mais
elle a conscience d'être une
communication politique une commune
questions publiques chirac sarkozy
hollande
avait une connexion avec le peuple
chirac
considéré que les français sont dans une
entreprise et qui le chef d'entreprise
sait c'est pas du tout les matchs
d'image qu'il donnait
surtout avec cette photo est
égaré un regret tout et qui avait fait
la fête tout cas d'après repas du monde
de
l'épreuve avait saisi même chose
oui michel tu es tu encore un communiste
un tueur
[Musique]
bon je peux taper dans quelques minutes
lorsque j'ai fait une interview au monde
et
je fais comme lui je fais deux annonces
je dirais les tiennent
regardons
aussi bonne que
la crise n'avait pas eu confiance dès le
départ dès le départ nous à nous à nous
infantiliser
les ors de la presse n'est pas dire en
tout cas c'est ce que ce qu'on a envie
que vous disiez donc on va vous parquet
on va réduire votre temps de travail et
c'est dommage pour l'actuel président ne
pas pouvoir ouvrir lé regard indépendant
quoi alors c'est soit soit sa
photographe personnel soit sur l'agent
spipoll qui aboie qui a fait allégeance
quoi aujourd'hui ça va vite parce qu'on
a un accès qu'à ses limites et quand on
rentre dans un bureau à l'elysée ou
ailleurs on sait qu'on va avoir 30
secondes 15 secondes une minute dans les
grandes et grands jours donc il faut
faut être prêt il faut il faut vraiment
balayer une scène très vite et aller à
l'essentiel et ensuite s'accorder un
temps pour essayer de décaler un peu son
image voulez donner du sens où c'est
difficile c'est très difficile
il ya beaucoup moins de spontanéité il
ya beaucoup plus de gens entre nous et
politique
des gens qui
je vais être un peu dur mais ne connaît
strictement rien à l'image naturellement
aujourd'hui tout est mis en scène toutes
les communications et la communication
domine le fond à mes yeux en tout cas
on considère qu' il n'y a pas de message
si la communication n'est pas réussi à
voir une belle page une bête double page
dans paris match ou une belle parution
dans libération je crois qu'ils s'en
foutent en fait parce que parce que ça
mais ça n'a plus la portée que peut
avoir un beau poste instagram ou un
message twitter
qui va être repris et repris repris donc
ils n'ont pas besoin de nous pour ça et
il s'agit à ce moment là à travers cette
communication politique
d'emprisonner
le journaliste et le photojournaliste
dans un cadre qui est celui
que l'on veut maîtriser non on va tous
bouger on va tous aller à droite à
gauche derrière par la fenêtre on va
tous pas parce qu'on vit peut-être un
peu parce qu'on a un peu des mauvais
garçons à des mauvaises filles mais en
tout cas aussi parce que c'est notre
boulot notre boulot
surtout sur de la photographie politique
c'est de décrypter l'analyse et l'image
qu'on veut nous faire faire
et de faire strictement inverse parce
que notre boulot c'est un boulot de
journaliste nous on le sait que ça va
craquer on sait que ça peut craquer on
sait qu'on nous dit que ça ne craquera
pas on sait que ça peut craquer et on
sait que ça va craquer forcément
emmanuel macron a déploré ce week-end la
trop lente reconstruction à saint-martin
et saint-barthélémy un an après le
passage de l'ouragan irene déplacement
cours duquel le chef de l'état a
multiplié les rencontres avec les
habitants
notamment à quartier d'orléans l'un des
villages les plus pauvres de saint
martin c'est là qu'a été prise la photo
depuis très commenté emmanuel macron
entouré de deux jeunes dont l'un qui
fait un doigt d'honneur marine le pen a
dénoncé une image impardonnable et
photographes qui étaient sur place et
notamment lovestruck qui a fait l'image
à biot blonde et m'a raconté que c'est
une visite dans un endroit qui a été un
peu qui n'était pas prévu c'est ça a
débordé ou effectivement mène le
maquereau a été appelé par des gens qui
étaient dans les étages
emballé par son élan est monté
directement et le photographe a suivi il
a fait son boulot il a fait évidemment
son boulot et cette photo elle et elle
choque parce qu'on n'est pas habitué à
voir ce président là
dans ce type de situation mais elle est
intéressante parce qu'on se rend compte
d'un coup d'une confrontation du
président avec ses personnages et une
espèce de dissonances visuel comme ça
l'histoire de maquereaux 1 il ya avait
un peu d'honnêteté c'est que quelque
part il voulait aller se confronter à la
population locale et l'écueil est que
quand on se confronte à la population
locale il peut y avoir parfois des
accidents ou des malentendus quand on
est communicant s'en méfier vachement de
la photo parce que ça reste quelque
chose qui reste et qui aujourd'hui qui
peut tourner en un seul instant sur les
réseaux en boucle à gauche à droite les
télés etc etc la moindre boulette
est mise en exergue d'une manière
incroyable sur sur les réseaux surtout
terre et compagnie hollande dès le début
et on l'a photographiée sous là sous la
pluie sur les champs-elysées dès le
début on s'est dit mais ces kits ce gala
est là avec la flotte sur le sur le sur
ses lunettes et tout de suite il a fait
rigoler plein de gens et du coup on l'a
dit mais non
obama obama il est il va sous la pluie
mais il n'est pas mouillé obama c'est
non mais françois hollande pourquoi le
mouillé les présidents ne va pas être
mouillé donc il n'est pas intelligent
donc il a passé il est pas à sa place
mais c'est faut revenir sur terre
à
en
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les choses changent pour une raison très
simple c'est le lecteur on n'achète plus
journal papier ou quasi pas les
quotidiens nationaux papier aujourd'hui
sont quand même en déclin depuis un bon
moment le web aujourd'hui
c'est une évidence pour tous les
supports de presse pour tous les médias
et donc nous en tant que photographe ça
nous permet d'avoir d'avoir un espace
qui était immense et bien l'espace qui
mais qui reste parce que le papier
journal avant comme on dit voilà
lendemain voilà ça sert à ça sert sur
les marchés on va les légumes le
numérique permet aussi de d'accueillir
des images qui sont moins convenue
et
évidemment sûrement beaucoup plus
indépendant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'image présidentielle a évolué et a
évolué aussi rapidement que la société
est en quelque sorte aujourd'hui on a
des chefs de l'état qui sont extrêmement
médiatisé et qui s'auto médiatise les
dires par les réseaux sociaux ils ont
leur propre chaîne de télévision ils ont
lors leur propre service de maquillage
de coiffure etc donc ils se préparent
ils vont chez le coiffeur avant il se
prépare comme des stars n'y a pas de
doute on les voit maquiller des fois mal
d'ailleurs
on n'est plus du tout sûr programme et
sont filmés 24 heures sur 24 six vont
dehors symboliquement c'est la star
academy et la politique c'est maintenant
ça existe
il court mais la raison il a raison il
faut fuir loin vite luan de tout ce
cirque
peut-être qu'ils ont besoin d'être
considérés comme des stars pour a connu
le plus largement possible en tout cas
leur mission aider est totalement
différente
sont là pour comment dire pour régir nos
vies pour régir les français et donc on
se doit d'essayer de de ramener une part
de vérité en tant que citoyen on est on
en a on a une carte de presse dans une
carte d'électeur donc on se doit de
ne pas déconner c'est très bien de les
considérer comme un comme faisant partie
du jeu médiatico
politique entertainment
star mais faut pas oublier que c'est
quelque chose de sérieux et que donc
quand on parle politique il faut parler
des vrais sujets et que quand on est
photographe politique il faut prendre ce
cet exercice là de la photographie cas
un peu particulier de la photographie
politique c'est un exercice sérieux
[Musique]